مياه البحر تحولت لللون الاخضر وانبعثت
منها رائحه كريهه وتصدرت هذه الصوره ترند
في تونس فما الذي يحدث فعلا
صور ومقاطع فيديو تداولها تونسيون لشواطئ
الضحيه الجنوبيه للعاصمه اظهرت تغير لون
البحر الى الاخطر وسط انبعاث روائح كريهه
والعطور كذلك على السلحفاه النافقه في
ظاهره اثار جدلا واسعا ومخاوف من تعرض
المنطقه للتلوث وزاره الفلاحه وصيد البحري
طمانه السكان بان ما حصل مجرد امر طبيعي
واوضحت في بيان ان تغير مياه البحر لللون
الاخضر يعود الى التكاثر الهائل للطحالب
الدقيقه التي تعرف بازدهار العوالق
النباتيه لكن ورغم تاكيد السلطات الرسميه
على ان الظاهره امر طبيعي الا ان بعض
السكان لا يزالون يعتقدون ان ما حصل له
علاقه بالتلوث